nothing like JFK
city black roll hey I'm Tom Geisel
telegraphic travel come around last
night like a visible and after with
parity shuttle my my name is Gabby
Thomas I've been telling you accountants
of equity i'm tripoli given a pedigree
to be enough pleasure my faculty putting
the work that I'm doing are the moving
furniture 11 it's been a long week how
to take a good hot shower but I'll say
they're going to be a short Friday
episode when I'll say that because of
all the travel give me an opportunity to
get into the comment dig in spend time
with you guys I feel incredibly sharp
and ready for next week's content
strategy execution topics and I just
some stunned that were 10 years in and
people don't realize the number one the
number one cleaning a sale the number
one way to win in this game of personal
brand brands that are marketing and
building and selling and engaging and
navigating through the social mobile web
is to read every comment is to answer
everybody have you answered everybody's
comments on on your on your Instagram I
said a lot of times in Ireland and
Belgium don't listen to what I say watch
what I do not doing 60-second Club for
kicks and giggles I'm not aggressively
using stories on Instagram or swipe up
for fun
I haven't Li engaged hardcore on
snapchat this week because it's good for
my health
these are [ __ ] strategies so I guess
what I'm saying is I'm really enjoying
getting to know all of you the things
you react to all those little hearts I'm
giving one Instagram all those replies
I'm giving you on Twitter all this stuff
I'm listening I'm listening everybody
thinks I'm talking
was just maybe the way I gave a hound do
inside no bang today I came that day
with all my heart
no games the play
lay your face
that I'm stacking back-rubbing up as
imagine wasting the weight of my passion
youngin was one with the heart of a lion
but rip with the flow of the dragon iMac
and I wonder whether this happened my
friends overs guess is my passion
Oh girls will call us and ask are we
doing I'm worried they just trying to
cash in I'm saying I act like I'm better
in the grave
I know my relationship - a buck gotta
pay the cost but I heard that a buzz
never take a look
so wanna just drink it off [ __ ] that I
wouldn't I drink it dawg I said
something different and better like
action I'm buzzing what buzzing I tell
them it's under my feet nobody's ever
sad
like that it was emphasized is it worth
that
be right back it's enough places I never
got my calibration we didn't like that
we've been working for like that so got
it like that
no friend if they got it
it was I think I came to write back give
it right back
what is it down to fingers like that I
don't like the other person and I
definitely like that
okay
today
okay when
[Music]
I gave a in fly low expenses